Mein Name ist Ekrem Özgüvali. Ich bin auch in dieser Station als Arslanast tätig.
Würde ich gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Guten Tag Herr Doktor. Ehrlich gesagt geht es mir nicht so gut. Ich habe hier wirklich lange gewartet. Wie kommt es denn eigentlich, dass man so lange warten muss?
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, dass Sie so viel erwarten müssen. Aber wir haben in der Notfall einen dringenden Notfall.
Deswegen müssen wir zunächst noch andere Notfallpatienten behandeln. Ich werde Ihnen sofort interessieren.
Okay, na gut.
Und wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie es mich bitte wissen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Silvia Hamas.
Silvia Hamas.
Hamas. Am Ende gibt es.
Können Sie bitte das Fahnen und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Natürlich Herr Doktor.
Silvia ist S-I-L-V-I-A.
Okay.
Und Hamas H-A-M-E-L-S.
Hamas. Frau Hamas, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann genau ist Sie geboren?
Herr Doktor, am 24.12.1963.
Noch einmal bitte.
Ich bin am 24.12.1963 geboren.
Okay, vielen Dank. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Hamas?
Herr Doktor, 1 Meter 87.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Hamas?
Etwa 89 Kiloherz.
Frau Hamas, was für Sie ist heute?
Ich habe seit drei Tagen starke Kopfschmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Drei Tage starke Kopfschmerzen.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Beide Seiten im Schlafbereich.
Beide Seiten im Schlafbereich. Okay.
Frau Hamas, strallen die Schmerzen irgendwann aus?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Strallen nicht die Schmerzen. Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Langsam aufgetreten? Vor drei Tagen?
Die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten?
Wie begenen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Stichend, brennend, sehend, dumpf, klopfend?
Es ist klopfend und pulsierend.
Es fühlt sich wirklich so an,
als würde jemand mit einem Hammer auf meinen Kopf schlagen, Herr Doktor.
Wie ein Hammer. Okay.
Wie Hammer schlagen. Okay. Ich verstehe.
Ich meine, Kopfschmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen haben im Moment.
Wie beschreiben Sie, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala,
nur kein Schmerzen, sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen bedeutet?
Wie beschreiben Sie Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, morgens etwa bei sechs.
Aber abends wird es schlimmer.
Ungefähr acht von zehn, Herr Doktor.
Acht von fünf. Abends. Aber morgens sechs.
Im Moment?
Ja, vielleicht. Ja, in diesem Moment würde ich sagen acht. Entschuldigung, sechs.
Brauchen Sie eine Schmerzmittele?
Lieber, Herr Doktor.
Oder können Sie am Ende aushalten?
Wie gesagt, der Vorzüge ist lieber eine Schmerzmittele.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen Allergie?
Ich habe eine Allergie gegen Penisillin, Herr Doktor.
Penisillin, Allergie.
Wie reagieren Sie auf Penisillin?
Auf Rötung, auf Jukras und Rötung, Herr Doktor.
Jukras und Rötung.
Gibt es noch andere Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Gott sei Dank habe ich nicht.
Gut, okay. Ich rufe sofort meine Schwester an und gebe Ihnen eine Schmerzmittele.
Danke.
Können Sie weiterführen?
Ja, natürlich bitte.
Gibt es bestimmte Auflöser für die Schmerzen?
Was meinen Sie? Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie einen Kopfverletzten?
Nein, Gott nein.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder?
Ja, sie sind dauerhaft da.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen versteckt?
Ja, abends und besonders bei der Arbeit.
Per Schilmacht.
Ja, ja.
Abends und bei der Arbeit. In Ruhe?
Natürlich ist es besser als abends.
Es lindert Sie in Ruhe?
Kann man so sagen.
Aber nicht ganz lindern. Nur teilweise.
Es ist ein Vergleich zu der Arbeit.
Ist das das erste Mal, dass Sie in der Arbeit ein Kiebeschwerden haben?
Ich kann sagen, dass es ein starker erste Mal ist.
Herr Behanz, ist das schon bei Ihren Hausarzt?
Nein Herr Doktor. Aber früher hatte ich immer wieder Kopfschmerzen.
Sie fühlten sich drückend an.
Ungefähr einmal im Monat.
Aber diese Schmerzen sind anders.
Meinen Sie eine chronische Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ja. Ich meine, so. Immer wieder habe ich einen Kopfschmerzen.
Einmal im Monat.
Aber die Kopfschmerzen, die ich darunter erleide, sind anders als die ich erwähnte.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe.
Habt ihr dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich nehme Ibuprofen. 600 mg.
Ibuprofen. 600 mg.
Aber das hat mir nicht geholfen.
Nicht geholfen?
Mir nicht geholfen, ja.
Frau Hammes, wissen Sie schon, Ibuprofen, 600 mg ist ein Rezeptpflichtmedikament.
Haben Sie noch ein Rezept?
Nein, ehrlich gesagt vom Rezept meines Mannes habe ich das gekriegt.
Ja, das Medikament gehört Ihres Mannes.
Ohne Erdbeutung.
Ja, das mache ich Herr Doktor. Danke für Ihre Achtung.
Bitte achten Sie darauf. Ohne Rezept, ohne Erdbeutung nehmen Sie bitte kein Medikament.
Das ist sehr sehr wichtig für uns.
Frau Hammes, haben Sie noch andere bestimmte Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Lehmungen, Hörstörungen, Sehstörungen, Schwindel?
Herr Doktor, ich hatte auch ein anderes Problem. Es gibt schwarze Flecken vor den Augen.
Sie haben vor Augen eine schwarze Flecken. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit wann? Seit gestern kann ich sagen.
Seit gestern. Gibt es noch Hörstörungen?
Nein, Gott sei Dank. Aber das stört mich, diese schwarzen Flecken.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Hammes?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe nicht.
Nachtschweiß, Kassenschweiß? Schwerze, Ausbruch?
Das habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie schon einmal Bewusstsein verloren oder Bewusstseinsveränderung?
Bewusstsein verloren habe ich nicht. Aber ich fühle mich auch schwindelig, Herr Doktor.
Ja, schwindelig. Seit wann? Seit gestern oder?
Ja, kann ich sagen. Seit gestern.
Seit gestern schwindelig. Okay. Ich habe das notiert.
Und Herzklopfen habe ich seit gestern.
Schwindelig und?
Ja, manchmal Herzklopfen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wassalasen?
Beim Stuhlgang oder mit Stuhlgang habe ich keine Probleme. Aber ich muss auf die Toilette häufiger als sonst.
Zu Wassalasen meine ich.
In der letzten Zeit müssen Sie als sonst häufig.
Ja, häufig als sonst. Und ich trinke viel Wasser, Herr Doktor. Ich habe ständig Durst. Etwa drei Liter Wasser am Tag trinke ich.
Wie viel trinken Sie pro Tag?
Etwa drei Liter Wasser.
Drei Liter. Ist das im Azo oder in der letzten Zeit?
In der letzten Zeit.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Schwellung bemerkt? Im Körper zum Beispiel?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Gibt es eine Veränderung beim Urin? Farbveränderung oder Geruch?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, aber häufiger als sonst muss ich auf die Toilette.
Okay. Gibt es Blut im Urin oder Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Frau Homas, schlafen Sie gut?
Ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht gut schlafen. Wegen dieser Schmerzen und häufiger Toilette, Handtrag, kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Okay.
Ich bin sehr müde, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Frau Homas, leiden sind irgendeine chronische Erkrankung. Zum Beispiel Rückerkrankung, Bluthochdruck oder zum Beispiel Migraine oder...
Ja, außer diesen Kopfschmerzen leide ich an Diabetes, Zuckerkrankung und Bluthochdruck.
Zuckerkrankung?
Seit acht Jahren leide ich an Zuckerkrankung und seit fünf Jahren an Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Aber in den letzten drei Jahren nehme ich gegen die Medikamente ein.
In den letzten drei Jahren nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck?
Gegen Bluthochdruck meine ich.
Gegen Bluthochdruck. Okay. Und was nehmen Sie gegen Diabetes? Schieblichstelle oder Medikamente?
Ich nehme dagegen Medformin 500 mg ein. Zweimal pro Tag.
Medformin 500 mg zweimal?
Ja, genau.
Morgen und Abend oder?
Ja, ja. Frühstück und Abendessen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder?
Natürlich muss ich regelmäßig, aber manchmal vergesse ich das einzunehmen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und was noch?
Gegen Bluthochdruck nehme ich Ramiplil 5 mg.
Ramiplil 5 mg?
Ja, einmal. Und Magnesium nehme ich regelmäßig einmal pro Tag.
Und bei Bedarf nehme ich gegen diese Kopfschmerzen Ibuprofen 600 mg ein.
Ibuprofen 600 mg. Bei Bedarf, aber bei Bedarf.
Ja.
Ich würde gerne wissen Frau Hamas, warum nehmen Sie Magnesium?
Gibt es noch eine Erste Scherzrate oder Medikamenten?
Mein Hausarzt hat empfohlen, weil ich Diabetes oder weil ich eine Suche Krankheit habe.
Er hat empfohlen.
Sehr gut.
Frau Hamas, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Herr Doktor, mir wurde vor etwa 10 Jahren die Gallenblase entfernt.
Gallenblase entfernt? Das war komplikationlos oder?
Ja, es war eine Bauchspiegelung. Sie sind durch meine Nadel gegangen. Ich habe kaum eine Narbe.
Okay, ich verstehe. Meine sind laparoskopisch.
Ja, die Ersten nennen es so.
Sehr gut. Gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay, nur Gallenblase entfernt.
Okay.
Und Sie haben noch gesagt, Sie haben eine Penisallergie.
Ja.
Und Frau Hamas, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich bin nicht Raucher. Ich bin stolz darauf, dass ich nie geraucht habe.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur gerächtlich, Herr Doktor. Zwei Gläser Prozeko oder Wein alle zwei Wochen.
Prozeko? Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie einmal Drogen ausprobieren?
Herr Doktor, ich rauche keine Zigarette. Sehe ich so aus, dass ich drogabhängig bin?
Nein, bitte denken Sie so nicht, Frau Hamas. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Weil manche Drogen mit bestimmten Medikamenten Nebenwirkungen oder Wegseilwirkungen haben können.
Deswegen frage ich.
Ach so, Sie haben recht.
Eine Routinefrage.
Ich brauche keinen Kontakt.
Frau Hamas, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Herr Doktor, leider ist mein Vater an Pneumokoniosis verstorben. Sie sagen so, Pneumokoniosis, Staublunge.
Wissen Sie?
Verstorben. Wegen Pneumokoniosis?
Staublunge, ja. Sie sagen Pneumokoniosis. Währenddessen konnte ich das erfahren. Deswegen so gesagt.
Warum ist Herr Doktor daran verstorben?
War er ein Bergwerker?
Ja, er war Bergwerker.
Deswegen Frau Hamas, das ist eine chronische, endspontliche Lungenerkrankung. Natürlich sehr gefährlich. Es tut mir leid.
Das war für uns sehr traurig.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Sie war sehr jung.
Ihre Mutter?
Ja, Gott sei Dank lebt meine Mutter noch. Aber sie hat Kniegelenkartose.
Knieprobleme.
Kniegelenkartose, ok.
Sie haben Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe vier Geschwister. Eine davon ist gestorben, leider, Herr Doktor.
Eine gestorben?
Ja, letztes Jahr. An einem Herzenfall.
Es tut mir sehr leid. Mein herzliches Beileid für Ihre Verlust.
Gott sei Dank sind die anderen gesund.
Gott sei Dank. Und Frau Hamas, was machen Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich bin Betriebsbuchhalterin.
Betriebsbuchhalterin. Verheiratet ihr?
Ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meinem Ehemann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Töchter, Herr Doktor. Sie sind Gott sei Dank gesund.
Ok, mein Freund.
Frau Hamas, Sie haben seit acht Jahren Diabetes, Rückerkrankheit und seit fünf Jahren Arterie für Patronien.
Ja, genau.
Und was machen Sie für diese Krankheit? Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Medikamentei?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie schon gesagt, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamentei, 500 mg. Aber wann war letztes Mal Blutstuckerkontrolle?
Herr Doktor, leider habe ich seit mehreren Tagen keine Teststreifen.
Ich wollte das verschreiben lassen, aber weil meine Hausarztpraxis seit zwei Wochen geschlossen ist, konnte ich das nicht schaffen.
Vor 15 Tagen war der Blutzucker erhöht.
Wurde er gemessen?
Vor 15 Tagen habe ich das gemessen, aber war er erhöht.
Könnten Sie mir vielleicht ein Blutzucker-Messgerät verschreiben?
Ja, natürlich.
Oder diese Teststreifen geben Sie mir?
Oder ein Blutzucker-Messgerät.
Nein, ein Blutzucker-Messgerät.
Ich meine, ein Blutzucker-Messgerät.
Ein Blutzucker-Messgerät kann ich Ihnen verschreiben.
Aber für den Blutzuckerstreifen brauchen Sie keine Rezept.
Ohne Rezept können Sie ihn in der Apotheke kaufen.
Ich habe gerade das erfahren.
Okay, ich mache so. Bei der Apotheke kann ich diese Teststreifen kaufen.
Ja, wissen Sie, Frau Hammers, das sollte regelmäßig kontrolliert werden.
Sehr wichtig für uns.
Alles gut, Frau Menemans. Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Sie.
Herr Doktor, meine Blutdruckwerte sind ein bisschen erhöht.
Gestern war es 150 zu 80 und heute Morgen 180 zu 90.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Vielleicht möchten Sie wissen. Deswegen habe ich gesagt.
Ja, sehr wichtig für uns.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Sie. Unkontrollierte Zuckerkrankheit und Bluthochdruck.
Deswegen werde ich zuerst Ihren Körper untersuchen.
Dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen.
Für das Labor, das besteht ein paar Untersuchungen.
Und dann eine Summe. Vielleicht brauchen wir ein paar entokonologische und kardiologische Konzill.
Bitte warten Sie hier.
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich warte auf Sie.
Ich bin mit meinem Obers und komme zurück.
So ist das für mich.
Okay.
Bis gleich, oder?
Ja, bis gleich.
Frau Obers.
Ich brauche eine Laboanruf.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Möchtest du eine Anruf machen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie mir eine Frage stellen?
Die Diabetes-Mellotus ist ein Typ.
Kann man verstehen, dass die Diabetes-Mellotus im aktuellen Anamnesis eine Typ ist?
Oder müssen wir die Anamnesis im Core-Erkrankungs-Tip ansehen?
Also, man kann sich an die aktuellen Anamnesen und die Wegetatib-Anamnesen befassen.
Man kann sich an die aktuellen Anamnesen und die Wegetatib-Anamnesen befassen.
Die Diabetes-Mellotus sind die Symptome des Kopfschmerzens oder der Schwindel.
Aber man kann es in der Anamnesis lernen.
Man kann sich an die Anamnesis lernen, ob die Diabetes-Mellotus in der Anamnesis kontrolliert oder nicht.
Okay, danke.
Normalerweise, wenn ein Patient in einem Kurs eine solche Anmerkung hat,
dann sagt er, dass er viel Wasser trinkt.
Wir fragen direkt.
Wir hatten direkt gefragt, ob wir an der Anamnesis des Core-Erkrankungs-Tips warten würden,
ob wir eine chronische Analyse haben.
Deswegen stellen wir uns nicht vor, das zu fragen.
Wir fragen an der Anamnesis des Core-Erkrankungs-Tips.
Ich hoffe, dass es eine Antwort gibt.
Danke.
Jetzt haben Sie mit Kopfschmerzen angefangen, aber nicht mit Polyurepolydikten.
Das Patient kommt mit Kopfschmerzen.
Denn das ist die Grundlage.
Der Patient spielt nicht die Rolle, weil er zu viel schläft oder zu viel in die Toilette geht.
Deswegen?
Deswegen habe ich mir gefragt, ob es andere Dinge gibt,
weil man an der Anamnesis der Anamnesis ein paar Tipps ausbreiten kann.
Aber hier kann man das nur aus der Core-Erkrankung fangen.
Nein, in der Vegetative Anamnesis kann man es fangen.
Es gibt ein Schwerpunkt, dass der Patient zu viel schläft und zu viel Wasser trinkt.
Das ist der Schwerpunkt.
Daher kann man sich über die Anamnesis der Diabetes-Merlitis wüssten.
Das sagt es auch in der Core-Erkrankung.
Dieser Patient, der Diabetes-Merlitis-Patient,
spielt die Rolle so.
Er kommt immer mit Kopfschmerzen.
Kopfschmerzen und Schwarze-Fo-Augun oder Flecke-Fo-Augun.
Das ist der Schwerpunkt.
Das sind die Schwerpunkte, die vor dem Kopfschmerz, die Flecke, die Flemme.
Das ist das, was er mit der Anamnesis und der Diabetes-Merlitis-Patienten zu tun hat.
Meira?
Ja?
Ich, Ekrem, wenn Sie mir das okay sagen,
habe ich zwei Bömerkungen, wie das hier in Danish.
Vielleicht kann ich Ihnen ein paar Dinge sagen,
was ich hier in der Anamnesis angeht.
Natürlich.
Und diese Diabetes-Fakade kam mir in der Anamnesis.
Das hier ist der Schwerpunkt von Flemern.
Flemern, vor den Augen.
Also hier, als ich in Schwarz's vor den Augen kam,
habe ich in die Schwindelung eingestellt.
Der Patient hat mir gesagt, nein.
Aber es gibt Schwindelungen im Protokoll.
Aber der Patient hat mir gesagt, nein,
damit ich nicht in die Schwindelung gehen kann.
Flemern, vor den Augen, sind generell die Lichtblasen,
die im Migrant- und Hypoglysema-Atau sind.
Ich habe das hier gefunden.
Ich werde es jetzt an die unteren Schwindelungen anziehen.
Ja, in Schwarz's Flak kann man auch Hypoglyseme sehen,
aber das ist eher selten.
Das sieht man in Hypotension-Atausen.
Dieses Fall hat mir in der Anamnesis etwas erinnert.
Leider war das eine Erfahrung im Anamnesis.
Wenn man in der 10. Minute die Vegetative Anamnesis endet,
kann man die 4-air cranking oder 8 Minuten lang
noch anwenden.
Wenn möglich, endet es in der 10. Minute.
Das heißt, 5-6 Minuten abbezüglich.
Denn in diesem Fall, wie der Herr Sumerer gesagt hat,
kommt die Anamnesis an.
Vegetative Anamnesie, Taha, Habanzy,
Fiber, ja, das ist schon die Schüttefrost.
Ja, sie hat auch einige Schwiegeswerte,
Schwiegeswerte, Flemern, vor den Augen.
Ich habe in der Saison zum Beispiel eine Frage gestellt.
Ist Ihnen Kauser-Schwindelung auf dem Boot?
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen dafür.
Ich hätte gesagt, ich würde die Metformine kassieren.
Ich sage es, weil ich hier viele Leute habe, aber es kann uns alle verfallen.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es nicht abzetsen und nicht stoppig wäre.
Also, es kann sich damit befassen.
Es kann sich damit befassen, dass es ein Fahschüppereffung ist.
Was war in der Laborsetilung?
In der Laborsetilung war die Hemoglobin 10,5, die Creatin 1,4, 46 oder so.
Ich habe das plötzlich vergessen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich würde die Metformine kassieren und die Lankseite-Insulin starten.
Aber ich bin in der Notaufnahme.
Die genaute Therapie ist nicht so.
Die Laborsetilung ist ein Anleitungsverfahren.
Die Laborsetilung ist eine niedrige Hemoglobinwerte.
Die Creatinwerte ist eine diese Werte.
Die Däuten auf Blah Blah hin.
Sie warten auf solche Dinge. Sie warten nicht auf eine Tätigkeit.
Sie fragen, wie Sie eine Tätigkeit machen.
Sie fragen. Ja.
Ich habe das nicht von Danis gesagt.
Ich habe das von Fahrung gesagt.
Er hat das nicht von mir gesagt.
Ich habe das von Ikra gefragt.
Er hat das gefragt.
Aber es kann auch von Ihnen und Ihrem Branche aus verändern.
Ich habe das von ihm gefragt, seit ich ein paar Jahre in der Familie war.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe Fehler gemacht.
Es war nicht so.
Ich muss das wiederholen.
Ich liebe der Sümayra-Hörer sehr.
Wir werden auf die Stellen, die wir kontrollieren können, schauen.
Wir werden auf unserer Weile weitergehen.
Ich hoffe.
Ja, wir gehen weiter.
Hier, wir nehmen die Laborenden, Efeke.
Okay.
Klink Klink.
Hallo, ich bin hier.
Guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Efeke.
Frau Redel, Hemoglobinwert ist 5,23 Gramm pro Dessiliter.
5,23 Gramm pro Dessiliter Frau Redel.
R E D E L.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Wörter Ihren Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Okay, vielen Dank Frau Efeke.
Okay, schönen Tag.
Ich regne das.
Guten Tag Herr Özyuvalı.
Woher kommen Sie?
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Seit 3 Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Ich lebe in Deutschland mit meiner Familie.
Warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Eine große Herausforderung haben wir wegen politischer Gründe.
Wir sind hier vor 3 Jahren.
Wegen politischer Gründe müssen wir nach Deutschland auswanderen.
Okay. Was haben Sie bisher gemacht in Deutschland?
Bisher haben wir Deutschkurs B1, B2 und Fachsprache von Kurs.
Sie sprechen immer Wie.
Warum?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Wie, Wir.
Sie meinen Sie und Ihre Familie?
Ja, alle Familie.
Alle Familie machen Sie zusammen einen Kurs?
Ja, alle Familie machen wir einen.
Die Kinder bei der Schule und ich und meine Frau bei dem Kurs.
Wir lernen alle seit 3 Jahren Deutsch.
Kein anderes Thema.
Ich glaube Ihre Kinder haben schon Deutsch sehr gut.
Die Kinder waren super.
Ist Ihre Frau auch Arztin?
Ja, die Kurskultur, die Reaktion und die Therapie sind Arztin.
Hat sie schon Fachsprachprüfung bestanden?
Nein, leider noch nicht.
Später helfen Sie Ihrer Frau während der Vorbereitung?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Frau Ipek hat mich aus dem Labor angerufen.
Sie berichtete, dass Frau Redel einen Hemoglobinwert von 5,23 Gramm pro Dessiliter hat.
Diese Werte sind deutlich niedrig.
Das ist eine Anämie.
Welche Art von Anämie wissen Sie?
Oder wie viele Art von Anämie gibt es?
Anämie, Klassifierung, Mikrosite, Kanzlein.
Und Normal-Site.
Mikrosite, Normal-Site.
Wie können Sie entscheiden, welche Art von Anämie?
Ich habe 1000 Korpuskulare.
Und 1000 Korpuskulare.
Und ich habe 1000 Korpuskulare.
Und ich habe LdV.
Rethyklosid-Differenzation.
Was ist Normal-Bereich von MCF?
MCF Normal-Bereich, soweit ich mich erinnere, ist zwischen 32 und 38.
MCF Wert liegt zwischen 83 bis 96 Fnt.
96, ja.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
86?
83?
Ja, 83.
96 Fnt.
Ich bin ein Politiker.
Ich habe das bei der Medizin erstmals gehört.
Okay.
Wissen Sie weitere Ursachen?
Herr Oberst, sollen wir für die Prüfung so vorbereiten?
Oder zum Beispiel diese Weise habe ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, letztes Mal habe ich diese Kenntnisse in der Medizinstudium gesehen oder gelesen.
Ich glaube, dass Sie diese Information mit Ihrem Oberarzt oder Oberarztin nicht mitteilen.
Okay.
Sie können einfach ... momentan fällt mir gerade nichts ein.
Vielen Dank für die Information und können Sie weiter.
Ich bereite diese Prüfung für eine Sprachprüfung.
Deswegen habe ich keine medizinische Kenntnisse.
Du hast Recht, das ist eine Sprachprüfung.
Du musst diese Information nicht auf jeden Fall wissen.
Aber du kannst diese Frage bekommen.
Und dann, obwohl du diese Information nicht wusst, kannst du auf jeden Fall eine Antwort geben.
Zum Beispiel, momentan fällt mir dazu nichts ein.
Ich habe es schon gelesen, aber leider kann ich momentan nicht daran erinnern, dass es auch eine Antwort ist.
Super.
Super, Entschuldigung.
Ich habe das gelesen, aber aktuell fällt mir nichts ein.
Deswegen entschuldigen Sie mich.
Was haben Sie heute noch für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Es geht um eine Frau Silvia Hamas.
Sie ist 63 Jahre alt und ist im 24.12.1963 geboren.
Sie ist 1,87 Meter groß.
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Weise richtig ist.
Sie ist 89 Kilo.
Silvia Hamas stellt sich heute bei uns seit drei Tagen stärker Kopfschmerzen beideseitig im temporalen Bereich vor.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Laut Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen vor drei Tagen langsam aufgetreten.
Sie berichten, dass die Schmerzen klopfen wie ein Hama schlagen.
Entschuldigung. Sie berichten, dass die Schmerzen wie Hama schlagen sind.
Wie Hama schlagen sind, ja.
Momentan korrigiere ich Ihre Grammatikfehler.
Ihre Satze sind schön, das gefällt mir.
Aber es gibt ein paar Grammatikfehler.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen wie ein Hama schlagen sind.
Die Schmerzen sind klopfend und drückend.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei morgens 8 von 10.
Am abends und bei der Arbeit liegt bei 8 von 10.
Dagegen nimmt sie bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 600 mg.
Aber das hat ein bisschen geholfen für die Schmerzen.
In der letzten Zeit, seit gestern Abend, das hat nicht geholfen.
Seit drei Tagen sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft.
Die Schmerzen verstärken sich bei der Arbeit.
Und abends lindert die Schmerzen in Ruhe.
Sie bildet auch, seit gestern hat sie vor Augen Schmerzen flecken.
Und ist ihnen schwindelig.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an Amnese ergaben sich eine chronische Kopfschmerzen.
Sie haben Schmerzen und Vegetative Amnesis.
Seit drei Tagen ist sie schwindelig.
Sie hat Schlafstörungen und Herzstolpern.
Sie fühlt sich häufig durch.
Sie hat ca. 3 Liter pro Tag getrunken.
Und wegen der Schmerzen eine dauerhafte Schlafstörung.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an Amnese ergaben sich eine chronische Kopfschmerzen.
Sie hat 8 Jahre Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2.
Dagegen nimmt sie mit Formen 500 mg täglich morgens und abends.
Sie können Vegetative Anamnese sagen.
Schlafstörungen, Schwindel, Herzklopfen, Zirkab.
Alle vegetativen Symptome können Sie in einem Satz nennen.
Vegetative Anamnese, Ergabpsik, Polydipsie, Polyure, Schwindel.
Sie haben Schmerzen und Schlafstörungen.
Bei der Vorerkrankung an Amnese ergaben sich seit 8 Jahren Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2.
Und seit 5 Jahren Atelel, Hypatonin und eine chronische Kopfschmerzen.
Mit Formen 500 mg täglich morgens und abends.
Sie haben die Blutzucker gut eingestellt.
Nein, leider nicht. Sie nehmen ihre Medikamente nicht regelmäßig.
Wann wurde ihre Blutzucker das letzte Mal gemessen?
Vor 15 Tagen hatte sie ihre Blutzucker gemessen.
Sie hat gesagt, die Blutzucker, ich habe das nicht notiert, aber ...
Sie hatte auch eine unkontrollierte Art der Hypatonie.
Die letzte Messung war 180 mmHg.
Sie wurde gemessen.
Und wegen der Hypatonie, Ramiplil 5 mg täglich einmal.
Magnesium Tablet und Klaredosis täglich einmal.
Ibuprofen 600 mg bei Bedarf.
Vor 10 Jahren hatte sie eine Voroperation.
Vor 10 Jahren wurde bei ihr eine Gallenblase entfernt.
Was ist der Fachbegriff?
Cholestectomy.
Sie ist keine Raucherin. Sie trinkt am Wochenende zwei Gläser Wein und Drogenkonsum.
Sie trinkt?
Sie trinkt am Wochenende zwei Gläser Wein und Drogenkonsum.
Sie wurde verneint.
Die Familienanamnese ergab, dass der Vater von Pneumokonios verstorben ist.
Die Mutter hatte eine kniggelenkte Erkrankung.
Conarthros?
Ja, Conarthros.
Sie hat vier Schwestern.
Eine Schwestern wegen einem Herzinfarkt, Pneumokoniosinfarkt, verstorben.
Sie ist Betriebsbuchhalterin. Sie lebt zusammen mit ihrer Familie.
Sie hat zwei Töchter. Sie ist gesund.
Sie sind gesund.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Stoffwechselerkrankung aufgrund Diabetes mellitus und unkontrollierter arteriöler Hypatonie.
Kopfschmerzen, Duft, Teststöten, Schlafstörungen und was soll ich sagen?
Polydipsy, Polyüri.
Ich spreche dafür.
Die Vorgeschichte.
Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2 und arteriöler Hypatonie.
Ich spreche dafür.
Ja, ich spreche dafür.
Die Differenz der Diaktose ist, dass sie nicht kommen und migrieren und eine trans-isemische Attacke betrachten.
Ich werde zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen und dann Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor Blutbild, Leber und Nierenwerte und Entsundungwerte und CAP, Chemoglobin, A1C und Ürungsstatus kontrollieren.
Dann eine CT-Schede und eine entnologische und neurologische Konzilanforderung.
Als Initialtherapie würde ich gerne empfehlen, zunächst eine Physikalsphore und Elektrolysisition.
Und Ernährungsanstellung und Antihypertension und Antidiabetik werden eingestellt.
Dann eine Patientenschulung empfehlen.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Ich muss meine Sätze wiederholen. Ich kann sie nicht so wie ich sie mir in der Kopfkarte vorstelle.
Aber ich werde sie wiederholen.
Wenn ihr ein Angehörige ist, dann vergesst nicht, die Zimt und die Lagen zu vergessen.
Wenn ihr ein Angehörige nicht ist, dann vergesst nicht, den Angehörige zu enden.
Als wir vorhin die Mühle vorgelegt haben, so eine Art Vorbereitung zu machen.
Ich habe das schon 2004 im Sommer gesehen.
Ich kann es noch nicht erinnern.
Wir haben es immer so geplant.
EAM, AYNE, SHITERKE, KLOPFENDE, KOB, SHIMERSEN, GEHABT, HAKLE.
Das war immer so. Das war so im Sommer.
Ich versuche jetzt seit 2 Monaten die Formatik zu verarbeiten.
Ich bin immer wieder in der Stresse.
Das ist der Normale.
Das ist besser, das ist leichter.
Aber ich bin immer wieder in der Stresse.
Dieses Mal bin ich etwas schrecklicher.
Nein, das ist nicht schrecklicher.
Du musst dich nicht so schrecklicher aussehen.
Du musst nur auf die Fähigkeiten achten.
Schönen Tag, Herr Scheter.
Ich wollte noch etwas fragen.
In der Dokumentation, in der Anamnesbogen,
in der Sprache, in der die Stimme begleitet wurde,
habe ich die Begleitenden geschrieben.
Begleitende, Klack, Zieh, Uba, bla bla bla.
Das können Begleitende sein.
Begleitende, Anamneste, Schergab,
die Begleitenden, Anamneste, Schergab.
Das kann Begleitende sein, aber auch Begleitende.
Das kann also sein, dass es eine Inzomnie gibt.
Das ist eine lange Zeit.
Du fragst den Patienten,
dass ich die Polydipsie, Polyuree in Begleitenden schreibe.
Du hast es gestern auch erwartet.
Ich habe es so verstanden.
Wenn du es über diesen Patienten erzählen,
dann machen wir es generell.
Begleitende, Anamneste, Schergab,
Begleitende, Anamneste, Schergab.
Das ist sehr speziell.
Man kann es auch in Begleitenden sagen.
Ich habe Ekreme hier 5, 6 Sagen gesagt.
Nur um Begleitende, Anamneste zu schicken.
Wie kann man es in einer Sagen erzählen?
Begleitende, Anamneste, Schergab,
Begleitende.
Das ist alles, um einen Sagen zu erzählen.
und eine wertvolle Säule in einer Sitzung zu sagen.
Aber normalerweise ist Polydipsy, Polyiru hier ein Begleit-Symptom.
Es ist nicht falsch, das zu sagen, aber
ich würde das Patient hier anzeigen, wie ich es so sagen würde.
Die Patienten sind in der Zeit, in der sie sich vertreten,
dass sie sich in einer temporalen Zeit vertreten,
dass sie sich in einer Zeit, in der sie sich vertreten,
langsam aufgetreten. Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen wie Hama-Schlag und persistierend
progredient sind. Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10 morgens und 8 von 10 abends.
Und begleitet klagt sie über Photopsie, wenn Sie wollen, vor den Augen.
Begleitet klagt sie über Photopsie, Polydipsie, Polyuree, Schwindel, vegetative Anamnestische Ergapsie,
Schmerzbedding, Dissomnie, Inapotens, und so weiter. Ich sage nicht die nicht existenten Dinge,
wenn es nicht zu einer sehr spezifischen Krankheit geht. Dann kommt die Anamnese, die
erwähnte sie seit acht Jahren Diabetes Mellitus Type 2 und seit fünf Jahren arterielle Hypertonie.
Leider sind die Teststreifen, ihre Teststreifen seit zwei Wochen ausgegangen. Deswegen hat sie
ihren Blutzucker nicht gut kontrolliert, aber vor 15 Tagen würde ihre Blutzucker von Hausarzt
überprüft und damals war der Wert sehr hoch und ihre Blutdruck würde auch nicht gut eingestellt.
Heute Morgen hat sie ihn gemessen und das war 180 zu 90 gibi.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen?
Vielleicht haben Sie sich am Kopf verletzt? Sind die Schmerzen da war?
Haft oder gehen Sie wieder weg? Ist es das erste Mal oder hatten Sie schon früher einiges Symptome?
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert?
Was ist das für eine Schmerzen?
Wenn der Patient zu Beginn Schmerzen hat, dann stelle ich die Schmerzen.
Manchmal sagt der Patient nur Schmerzen und manchmal sagt er Schmerzen und dann sagt er Schmerzen.
Wenn ich die beiden sagen würde, dass sie Schmerzen haben, Schmerzen und Schmerzen vor den Augen haben,
dann haben Sie die beiden Schmerzen beidseitig.
Wenn Sie die beiden Schmerzen beidseitig haben, dann starten Sie mit einer Schmerzen.
Dann starten Sie mit einer Schmerzen und fragen Sie sie und dann gehen Sie zu der anderen Schmerzen.
Wenn Sie beide Schmerzen beidseitig haben, dann starten Sie mit einer Schmerzen und fragen Sie sie.
und dann ist es die Bitesite oder Bitesite, die du nennen kannst, weil wenn du nur eine Seite hast,
dann ist es die Glockomusik, deswegen ist es wichtig, das zu fragen.
Wann hast du das gesagt?
Du hast nur eine Seite, Bitesite oder Zwei-Side?
Du hast das gefragt und das auch.
Jetzt, weil die ein bisschen mit Neurologie sind,
habe ich mir die Fragen von Koppschmerzen und Gözde vorgelegt.
Ich habe die neurologischen Fragen vorgelegt.
Wie ist dein Fingernis?
Hast du dich verloren?
Hast du dich verletzt?
Wie ist dein Fingernis?
Wenn er das gesagt hat, habe ich ihn nicht gefragt.
Hier, hier.
Schau, die neurologischen Fragen kommen mit Koppschmerzen.
Wenn sie so kommen, dann frage ich sie.
Dann frage ich sie.
Ich bin jetzt mit einem Namen zu sprechen.
Sie haben Fieber, Stülpflos,
das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr große Ausbruch.
Sie können nicht gut schlafen,
weil sie sehr stark schmerzen.
Sie sind sehr apathisch.
Sie haben ein Problem,
dass sie nicht gut schlafen können,
weil sie sehr stark schmerzen.
Sie können nicht gut schlafen,
Das kann man auch sagen.
Sie können empathisch sein
und sie können aus einem
Ausbruchkomplace ver eyelashes binden.
Dann gibt es
ein halbes System,
ein Übungen,
einen Übelruf,
ein Erdbruch,
eine Schmerzen,
eine Schmerzenprobleme...
...
Die Chemie kann
sich in diesen neuen Systemen
Wie viel üben sie? Wie viel haben sie? Wie viele sind sie? Wie viele sind sie? Wie viele sind sie?
Müssen sie auf in der Nacht zum Wasser los?
Mixium-Messwerte und andere Dinge frage ich sie.
Sie fragt, ob sie so eine starke Durstbemerkung haben.
Gibt es eine sehr große Wasserunfall?
Haben Sie es bemerkt?
Wie viele Wasser trinken sie täglich?
Ich habe hier eine Analyse.
Ich werde die Fragen, die mit dem Arzt zu tun haben, in die Kommentare drücken.
Und dann kommt die Analyse von der Foyer-Kranken.
Die Analyse der Foyer-Kranken ist wichtig.
Warum? Weil es hier die Diabetes-Mellitus, Arterie-Hypertonin gibt.
Hier müssen wir die Patienten sicherlich fragen.
Die Diabetes-Mellitus ist eine Blutszika.
Wenn sie Blutszika haben,
können sie das nicht.
Sie können das nicht.
Die Diabetes-Mellitus ist ein Psychopath.
Sie haben nur Metformin.
Sie können sich nicht sehr gut ausüben.
Die Diabetes-Mellitus ist regelmäßig ein Psychopath.
Das müssen wir auch fragen.
Die Diabetes-Mellitus ist eine Blutszika.
Die anderen werden in eine ähnliche Form.
Das sind die Fragen.
Ich habe zuerst die Reaktionen zu den Diabetes-Mellitus-Kranken erwartet.
Ich habe immer gefragt, ob es so ist, dass es so schnell geht.
Dann kannst du die Schmerzmittel sofort auf die Schmerzen geben.
Diese Aar-Reaktionen.
Dann kannst du die Blutszika- und Bluthochdruck-Messungen...
Hier habe ich immer gesagt,
Ich verstehe, dass Ihre Teststreifen ausgegangen sind.
Aber es ist sehr wichtig, regelmäßig Blutszika- und Blutdruck zu messen,
damit wir das Problem so früh erkennen und eine beste Therapie planen können.
Wenn Sie nicht wissen, dass es so schnell geht,
dann können Sie mir eine Teststreifen geben oder Blutszika- und Bluthochdruck-Messungen schreiben.
Wir können das nicht so schnell schreiben.
Das kann nur der Endrochroniker oder der Diabetologe oder der Hausarzt schreiben.
Denn es gibt bestimmte Schaltkarten.
Wie die Anleitung, die Schmerzen, etc.
Aber wir können das so sagen.
Ich kann Ihnen ein paar Teststreifen von Krankenhaus geben.
Später können Sie darüber mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Ich werde Ihnen ein paar Teststreifen geben.
Dann können Sie mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Blut-Messgerät ist nicht hier, aber in einem anderen Fall,
in einem anderen Teststreifen, in einem anderen Teststreifen,
kann ich Ihnen ein Teststreifen schreiben.
Ich werde Ihnen ein paar Teststreifen geben.
Ich werde Ihnen ein paar Blutdruck-Messungen schreiben.
Natürlich, aber darüber werden Sie mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Sie müssen Ihren Hausarzt sprechen.
Aber ich werde Ihnen ein paar Blutdruck-Messungen schreiben.
Wir können das nicht schreiben.
Ich glaube, das ist schon ganz logisch.
Ich habe das eine Mal gesehen.
Ich habe an der Zeit einen Angriff, einen Stress,
den kann ich auch aufsteigen.
Es kann nicht so ein Unfall sein.
Es ist nicht sinnvoll, einen Patient zu folgen,
den ich nicht verfolgt habe.
Ich habe diese Antworten gegeben.
Ist es noch eine andere Reaktion?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe ein paar Reaktionen gegeben, aber die beiden haben auch etwas.
Wir haben schon die Reaktionen von Drogge gesagt.
Das kann nicht so ein Begriff sein.
Das kann auch ein Begriff sein.
Wenn das eine Reaktion ist,
ich kann das nicht erinnern,
aber wenn das eine Reaktion ist,
dann kann ich das so sagen.
Ich glaube, ich würde das so machen.
Das ist ein hoher Übergewicht.
Ich glaube, wenn wir die Reaktionen von Drogge machen,
können wir diese Werte wieder aufnehmen.
Ich glaube, es gibt andere Reaktionen.
Das ist normal.
Das ist normal hier?
Aber manche sind von Gewichtssapnamen gesprochen.
Vielleicht gibt es eine solche Variation.
Es gibt auch andere, die es nicht haben.
Gewichtssapnamen.
Wenn ich zuerst in der Verkaufsrunde bin,
dann ist es mir sehr früh,
dass ich etwas machen muss.
Wenn das so ist, würde ich meinen eigenen Stil wollen.
Ich sage ja, nein, ich werde nicht beantragen.
Ich werde nicht so viele Recommende geben.
Ich würde das mit dem Ausdruck auf meine Gesichter zeigen
und weiter machen.
Natürlich kann die Situation
von jedem eigenen Stil verändern.
Oder das kann man auch so sagen.
Das ist ein bisschen viel.
Aber können wir gucken.
Wir, wir beurteilen.
Wir können das beurteilen.
Und wir können beginnen,
wenn es etwas mit dem Stil gibt,
dann können wir darüber reden.
Tümük, hast du dir etwas gemacht?
Ich werde in der Therapie schauen,
was ich in der Labo machen werde.
Für Diabetes.
Willst du es für uns machen?
Die Diagnostik von Vartyre.
Ich werde es jetzt machen,
weil es fertig ist.
Aber normalerweise habe ich meine Dokumente
schon sendet.
Es gibt einen Nup.
Ich hoffe, dass es besser ist,
dass ihr den Nup hört.
Es ist besser, den Nup zu halten.
Danke.
Ich werde auch die Patienten
mit der Diabetes beurteilen.
Ich werde die Migräne und die Tierkontrolle
beurteilen.
Ich werde es auch machen.
Ich werde die weiteren Abklärungen
erst mit der Körperversorgung vornehmen,
die Vitalparameter überprüfen
und Blut für das Labo abnehmen.
Natürlich werde ich ein EKG schreiben.
Im Labo werde ich Blutbild,
Entzündungsparameter,
wie sehr reaktiv Protein und
Nierenwerte, Lager,
Elektrolytewerte, Blutzucker,
Hemoglobin A1,
Blutgasanalyse
und Gerundungsparameter
bestimmen lassen.
Als Apparativ werde ich
CT-Shadow
die Tierkontrolle
überprüfen.
CT-Shadow
wird die Tierkontrolle
durchführen.
Ich werde einen Konsul
in der Abteilung
für Endokrinologie
und gegebenenfalls Neurologie
anfordern.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose
bestätigen,
sollte die
Patienten stationär aufgenommen werden.
Die Patienten
sollen Flüssigkeit zuvor,
Elektrolyte Substantien,
symptomatische Behandlung,
als symptomatische Behandlung
für Anarchetika,
Antiemetika
erhalten.
Wie ich gesagt habe, werde ich einen
Konsul
in der Abteilung Endokrinologie
anfordern.
Je nach Befunde
werde ich einen Konsul
in der Abteilung Endokrinologie
anfordern.
die
Ich glaube, die, die sich auf die Sicherheitsplätze anbieten, sind Rume oder ...
Ja, das habe ich normalerweise so gesagt.
Aber in den letzten Zeiten, in denen ich gearbeitet habe,
habe ich mir gedacht, dass ich eine von diesen beiden in den Kopsch-Mersen-Tür schreibe.
Ich habe mir gedacht, dass ich eine von diesen beiden in den Kopsch-Mersen-Tür schreibe.
Das kann auch in Tia sein.
Es gibt Kopsch-Mersen, dann gibt es eine Sechstörung,
oder so eine Flakafaulung.
Das ist nicht unbedingt ein La.
Es gibt ein paar neurologische Symptome.
Ich frage die anderen, ich werde die beiden sagen, das habe ich mir geplant.
Vielen Dank.